things that I wanted to share with you
according to Pew Research the net worth
of white families in 2013 was one
hundred and forty one thousand for black
families it was eleven thousand even
less than the 19 thousand it was in 2007
according to economist Edward wolf of
the University of New York excluding
vehicles and other durables the median
black family worth is just seventeen
hundred dollars well forty percent of
black families have zero or negative
wealth white family worth in terms of
financial worth is sixty nine times more
than that of black families given this
disparity how can you argue that racism
is not a driving factor in income
inequality because it has nothing to do
with race and everything to do with
culture and when you have a culture that
doesn't anyone and when you know what
explain to me you explain to me why
black kids aren't graduating high school
explain that one to me explain to me why
black kids are shooting each other in
rates significantly higher than whites
are shooting each other explain me why
thirteen percent of the population is
responsible for 50 percent of the murder
explain to me why they why the number of
blacks and black kids in prison not for
innocent reasons not for walking down
the street getting pulled into a prison
is so high explain if it has nothing to
do with culture explain to me why the
single motherhood rate in the black
community jumped from 20 percent to 70
percent in the same course of time that
the civil rights movement has made such
tremendous strides is America more
racist now than it was in 1960 and if it
is please explain to me how that
happened so what do I think those riots
are I think the depravity I think
they're thugs and I think if you really
want to make a difference Thurgood
Marshall who grew up just two blocks
from there
did such a thing who was a contemporary
of Martin Luther King
now I'd like to skip over to doctor
Seacrest I look at the Baltimore
uprisings
it's more than just riots right I hate
the idea when you say thugs and riots
right white people write it as well when
y'all win Super Bowls two years in a row
y'all get off the hook don't make it
seem like it's just Baltimore getting
upset
so my thirty second answer is I feel the
frustration of what's happening in the
community and I think it's a symptom the
the uprisings are a symptom of a
pressure that's been unaddressed for too
long and I'm offended by the language of
uprising applied to people who are
breaking into other black people's
stores and looting them this is not this
is a lack of values and people who
people who are destroying private
property destroying cop cars in an
uprising against what exactly against
the black police chief against a mostly
minority police force against the black
mayor against the black presidents
against the black attorney general
against the entirely against a City
Council that is 9 to 15 hour black and
all 15 are elected Democrats what is the
uprising against what is it seeking to
achieve I still don't see what exactly
the riots are seeking to achieve bottom
line is this is all it all could be
boiled down to just act like a mensch
act like a human being
honestly it's not a useful it's not
useful to riot it's not useful to break
things it's not useful to throw rocks at
people and the idea that we're supposed
to sort of correlate long away I'm gonna
stick to the 30 seconds yeah the idea
that we're supposed to correlate your
level of outrage with a certain level of
justification in other words the more
outraged you are and more angry you are
the more justified you must be as
absolute nonsense
[Applause]
then since the issue of disparities has
come up a number times when does
disparity not indicate racism
statistical disparity you know for
example overwhelmingly men commit crimes
more than women but we don't say that
the Justice Department is sexist
so is there is there a line that you
draw for yourself or is there some some
way that you interpret statistical
disparity and you determined that that
is not a racial disparity it's something
else
well we can return to it that's okay to
you Ben did you want to yes it's it's
called evidence of racism when there is
no evidence of racism it's probably not
racism when there is actual evidence of
racism it's probably racism and the fact
that everybody jumps from there's
inequality in therefore there is
inequity does not mean there was sorry
Charles I want to ask you a question so
your default your default is that when
there is no evidence racism is the
deciding factor no no no it's not saying
it I'm just saying that that you're
gonna have sexist you're gonna have
racist you're gonna have all this stuff
I mean I'm just say that I agree it
exists but the problem that I'm seeing
and this is the problem with the general
conversation is that there's no solution
and simply saying there's racism out
there how does that solve anything and
when when you talk about there's
institutional racism what does that mean
show me a law that is racist in intent
and we will agree show me a police
officer who commits a racist act like we
saw in South Carolina right where a
police officer shot a black man running
away and it was obviously unjustified
and I will agree but you need the idea
that you can craft a narrative based on
no racism because it just must be
somewhere out there in the ether that
doesn't solve problems for anybody
creates more problems for people because
now they grow up in a milieu and an
environment where they are told that
every obstacle they face is from some
shadowy nameless faceless group who is
out to get them simply because of the
color of their skin they'll never
succeed in that environment
[Applause]
you know the weirdest thing is that
actually in the black home as I
experienced it really there is no
discussion of racism racism much is a
discussion that you actually come out
and you face in in the public because
it's a real thing that you have to
actually expect I mean if you you're
silly and you foolish if you don't if
you don't really think that that's gonna
be there and encountered in the real
world I'm sorry this is just a fact of
life but if I'm at home and having
dinner with my father or whatever we
don't go oh my god
this society so racist as am eating my
steak and you know what I mean
goodness gracious oh I can't bear it my
black skin is causing and we know we
know we don't talk like we don't talk
like that we talk about my god aunt
what's-her-name oh my god she's got to
take some pills cuz she's off the
register I mean these are the
conversations we have at home we don't
have these kinds of conversations that
we're having right now at least my
childhood we didn't have them and I'm
watching the people I knew growing up in
the black neighborhood I didn't hear
anybody really talking about race when
we're at the dinner table I mean just
didn't pop up unless it was in the issue
was on television but mostly was about
family and and regular life but I
disagree I have to tell you even in my
culture there is an underlying racism
and I know that the panel today and
especially what's going on America we're
talking about white on black but you
cannot I cannot wake up in the morning
and not think about you know
interculturalism okay I'm not Mexican
enough why because I'm articulate and
because I have straight hair and I can
wear high heels I don't have a tattoo on
my neck yes there is a huge problem of
the racism no matter if you're
light-skinned or dark-skinned absolutely
there is intercultural racism it's
absolutely underlying and why you may
not talk about it your grandmother will
have the Freid grandkid if she's the
lightest one with the good hair that
becomes the favorite grandkid in our
culture and that's you know
unfortunately even within our own
cultures we tend to look upon you know
the color of each other's skin and how
much education we have and if my uncle
has done time in jail which you know he
has then he becomes more Mexican than I
am
what is up with that I mean it's sad but
it's true it's absolutely true it's like
I
spicy picante sauce so I'm not Mexican
enough you know it's true you know in
every culture whether it's Asian you
know black Mexican there is why you may
not have grown up talking about it over
your you know a tea and toast I mean in
my family for not a doctor or a lawyer
you're not Jewish not Jewish enough it's
true that part is true
this entire time I've been trying to
think about your initial question about
disparities are they automatically tied
to race and at first I think all of us
were stumped because we're trying to
think of the instances I I do agree that
they are separate but they don't
necessarily correlate within itself
there are disparities in double-a-c-p we
are the experts inside of the nation of
bringing in the racial lens for all of
the work no they're not necessarily
going hand in hand or they do not
necessarily tied to each other so that
was that's how I would answer it no they
don't have to go together my job as a
civil rights attorney is to be able to
make you see race at every given
opportunity but know it's not present in
each and every single disparity to your
second the standards what are the
standards the difference I mean you said
that you want people to see race in
every single issue where the present
where it's present okay so for instance
our standard as to where its present
absolutely what's my for that take
something as simple as a if we're
talking about a disparity say men and
women my job would be to show what does
that look like when you have women from
a different group communities of color
what does it look like when we're
talking about a woman who's working or
stuck in a minimum-wage job not being it
not as a starter but for her career so
we bring in the racial dynamic all right
how about if I understand that the
question that I'm asking is when do you
decide something racist has occurred
races yes like when it when do you have
you - when can you decide that an act of
racism has occurred because if you have
just a statistical disparity has it
Rhett has an act of racism automatically
accorded that was David's basic question
I think
right there's a there's obviously a
there might be a there will be a
disparate impact on different groups of
people that doesn't necessarily mean I
think what you're saying it doesn't
necessarily mean something racist is
going on even though there's a racial
impact so the question was about where
do you draw the line between something
that might have a racial impact but it's
not inherently racist
let me move on